jessica you got me fired up all right
let's go back to the phones let's go to
stephanie in richmond virginia
stephanie good morning how can i help
hi good morning john thanks for taking
my call thank you for calling
absolutely um so i wanted to call and
get your opinion
um my father um just passed away
it was i'm so sorry thank you so much um
it was an estranged relationship for
about
15 years and right now he's survived
by um his father and two brothers and
both all of them have very very bad
financial situations
um so at this point there's really
nobody except for me to
pay for a burial um
and i'm just not sure that i really want
to
and i'm kind of looking for guidance on
how to
how to go about thinking about this and
deciding this wow thank you so much for
the call first
and foremost man i'm sorry for your loss
even a strange relationships and messy
relationships there's just something
about
when our mom and dad passes away right
that hits us in our guts
why was your relationship estranged so
he and my mother um
got divorced when i was about five years
old and um it was due to alcoholism and
drug use
and then he just never actually um
made it past that and unfortunately
passed away due to those
circumstances
and all of those elements are present in
the other family members lives as well
so it's really
it's a bad situation with all of them um
and unfortunately my father passed away
from it so
we've spoken maybe three times in the
last
10 years um for just a couple of minutes
at a time
so the the way i first and fore
let me give you a couple things here i'm
kind of stumbling over my words here a
little bit
first and foremost you've got no
obligation to pay for anything okay
um i want you to there is no rule
there's no hard and fast
um issues here
if i mean he gave up his right to be a
dad he left you as when you were five
and uh he spent most of his life in
devotion drugs and alcohol and other
things
and so there is no um
no requirement that you pay for this
right the way i
like to look at these situations is a
saying that i heard years ago and that
has stuck with me
across a number of different issues
which is not by my hand but in my lap
meaning there are a number of things in
my life that i have to deal with
that i didn't cause that aren't my fault
that i
technically don't have a responsibility
to deal with but they are in my lab
um and i didn't um
hit a guy on the side of the road but
he's bleeding he's in
the right thing for me to do right now
is to help him up right the thing that
i'm not gonna sleep tonight unless i
don't do it
and so the question you have to ask
yourself is five years from now 10 years
from now 15 years from now or
30 minutes from now what is who is
stephanie
what is the character of stephanie um
and are you a person that would step in
if somebody at your local church needed
some help to pay for a
funeral um or are you somebody that
would would
pitch in five years from now and help a
brother who's struggling
you just gotta ask yourself that and
what you're gonna be able to sleep with
and not sleep with
um and that that is the character
question
that ends up dictating a lot of my
present day behavior
on uh not i'm angry right now but
who do i want to remember myself as
years from now
so do you have little kids i do
yeah i have um i have a six week old and
a two-year-old
did they ever meet their grandad
my two-year-old did one once
how did that go it was okay
um it he
you know wasn't overly involved but he
was happy to see
um and meet my son so what do you want
to do
um i don't
i don't know i think you know i'm open
to
probably paying for something simple and
helping out in that regard
um i just i might be maybe a little
overly pragmatic but it's hard for me to
really see
um what purpose it would serve
at this point which with him already
being gone it doesn't actually help
the reconciliation there the
relationship um
but in the same way i don't want to seem
cruel or to
um you know violate my own character and
regret that later
yeah and i think thinking about
reconciliation
as a two-sided way you're right he's
passed away
what a ceremony can do in the grieving
process even in a painful grieving
process how
again however big small medium-sized
ceremony there is
right even if it's a the least expensive
cremation
in a tiny urn that you deal with on your
own
um this
the reconciliation comes from your side
it's it
gives you a process to set the bricks
down
it gives you an opportunity to say you
can't hurt me anymore
you can never hurt my grandkids you
can't abandon me anymore
and in my last moment i took the high
road i forgive you
i'm setting the stuff down and i'm gonna
be
the mother i'm gonna be the parent
i'm gonna love my kids i'm gonna love my
husband i'm gonna love the people close
to me like you never did
and then you're gonna set that stuff
down and then you're gonna move on
and again that doesn't mean you have to
pay for a funeral it absolutely doesn't
you can do that with a letter to
yourself in an open field somewhere in
nebraska for all i care
um what i don't want you to do is let
your anger
and the shortsightedness and the
it doesn't have an immediate roi it
doesn't solve stuff
right now i don't want that to pain you
five years from now and ten years from
now and you think man for a thousand
bucks
for 500 bucks i don't i don't know how
much these things cost anymore
um for 2 500 bucks i could have taken
the lead in my family
once again as the only one who's not an
addict is the only one who sticks around
is the only one who does their
commitments
i paid for dad's a small little
get-together
i bought the cheese platter and i got a
minister in to say a couple of nice
words
i did the right thing i honored my dad
even when my dad
didn't honor us and then i put those
bricks
down and then i got about the the hard
work
the challenging work of moving forward
right of living into my family
my partner and making sure that we're
all on the same page moving forward so
that's totally up to you there's not a
right or wrong here you don't owe the
man anything
um if i'm in your position i would pay
for it
i would find the money i would pay for
it because it's at this point it's about
my character it's about
the the man i want my kids to see me
be not by my hand but in my lap
and i'm gonna that's the way i would
handle stephanie so thank you so much
for the call that's a hard hard one
you